All right. Good afternoon everyone.
Thank you. Welcome to AISD. Great to see
so many uh familiar faces here today. Um
so welcome to the AISD board auditorium
for the joint subcommittee. Uh today's
meeting is being broadcast live on AISD
TV, channel 22 on Spectrum and channel
99 on AT&T Universe. So as the board
president for Austin D. I will serve as
today's presiding officer. Uh I'll call
the meeting of the joint subcommittee to
order at 11:52 a.m. So I would like to
show that the following members are
present. Um if you are an elected
official and you're here, please um
state your name and position. Alison
Nalter, council member, District 10,
Austin City Council.
Bridget Shay, Travis County
Commissioner, Precinct 2.
And I'm Ryan Alter, Austin City Council,
District 5.
And on Zoom, we have
Trusty Sabata, District 2. Thank you.
So, we will um we do not have any public
comment today, so we will just move
right in.
So, uh, the first item is, uh, to
approve the meeting minutes for January
22nd. Uh, and you'll see those minutes
are in your binders.
Approval. Yes. All right. So, we have a
motion to approve and a second. So, a
motion from Bridget Shay and a second
from Allison Alter. Um,
guess we should call to vote. All those
in favor to approve the minutes, raise
your hand. All right. The motion passes
unanimously. Thank you. So, next on the
agenda is after school care. Um, there
is also a written report in your packet.
Travis County will uh provide a report
on afterchool care at our June meeting
and we've set aside 30 minutes for the
presentation and questions and answers
uh for today. So, there are written
materials in your notebook. And today we
have um some really talented afterchool
folks here. We have Jeremy Martell. Did
I pronounce that correctly?
Okay. Um, from AISD and Kimberly McNeely
from a Austin Parks and Recreation
presenting. So, welcome and whenever
you're ready, the floor is yours.
Hi, my name is Jeremy Martell. I'm the
director for the AISD third base after
school program and I'm here today to
talk about um kind of the direction our
program is headed.
We're not moving
Um the ASD after school program has been
in Austin for over 25 years. Um at its
peak previous to this year, it was at
seven elementary locations. Um after the
pandemic, the um program saw a decrease
in enrollment um to around 100 students
at five campuses. Um the district
recently made a commitment to revitalize
the program and expand to all of the
elementary school campuses within its
boundaries. Um and we decided to do this
in three phases.
Um phase one um will occur during the 23
24 school year, which is the one we're
currently in. Um which is at 24
locations. Phase two, which will be
2425, is going to expand to 16 more
locations. And then in phase three, um
during the 2526 loca um school year, we
will expand to 38 locations. Um those
locations are detailed in your uh
packets.
Um the tuition rate comparison for the
ASD thirdbased program. Um we are the
cheapest program provider in our
district. Um currently it's $275 per
month. Um compared to some of the other
providers that are in our current
campuses.
Um, we also, since we're a licensed
program, are able to accept some tuition
assistance and subsidies for our um,
students and families um, from Workforce
Solutions, City of Austin, Childcare
Aware of America, ACC, and we have our
own third base afterchool financial aid
assistance program as well.
Um, summer camp, we are running four
summer camps this summer, expanding from
two from the previous year. We have
increased the capacity from 100 to 400
students um and the increase the number
of weeks offered this summer from 7 to
10. Um we currently have two summer
camps that are full and on waiting list
and we have two more that are currently
accepting registration.
And that is the end of the presentation.
Thank you. All right. Um do we have u so
let's open this up to discussion. Um, so
folks, you'all have any questions for
sure? Welcome.
All right. So, now I am rarely asked to
talk loud.
Okay. All right. But, um, I'm I want to
make sure that I understand your
existing capacity issues. I think you've
laid out good information for us. I'm
interested in the uh the need issues as
well. Uh not only the capacity that you
have on campus, how many you serving,
but how many are on the waiting list in
each in each area? And do we have an
idea of what it would take to get to all
of those students?
Sure. Um yes, sir. The there is a great
need at several campuses which are
listed in the in the packet as well, but
the um the need we have is staffing. We
need to continue to recruit and hire
staff to accommodate the students
because being a licensed program we have
certain ratios that we need to meet to
meet the compliance. Um at some campus
there's also space issues. Um Lee
Elementary School for instance had
they're serving over a 100 students and
there's close to 60 students I believe
on that wait list and it's simply we
just don't have a place to put them
after school. Um there are classrooms
there but the teachers are usually there
till four o'clock which means we can't
put the kids in those rooms during after
school. So there's some capacity issues
at some of the campuses simply because
of the size. Okay. And I want to better
understand your capacity issues
particularly as it relates to available
personnel. I'm sorry. I want to
understand your capacity issues as it
relates to available personnel. meaning
um uh we know where we know where the we
know what our numbers are in terms of
need. I would need x number of teachers.
If I were going to take x number of
students off the waiting list, how do I
get from here to there? Very
interesting. Um our targeted ratio is 1
to 18. Um so in order to be able to take
more students, um from a staffing
perspective, for every 18 students, we
would need one staff member to to be
able to work. Um,
and then we do have the full-time staff
that are there as well, but we've
already filled all of those positions in
terms of we have a full-time director on
site at those campuses. So, it's mainly
the part-time staff and we're having a
hard time recruiting the part-time
hourly staff members. Um, we are getting
some applications trickle in here and
there, but um, it has been quite the
challenge. So in order to increase the
the number of students at each campus,
we need 1 to 18 is what our target range
is for our program.
Uh Commissioner Trafillian and maybe
something we can discuss. It'd be
interesting to know what are some of the
barriers right that are keeping us from
filling those positions. If you could
speak to that just based on what you've
heard. I know we have some applications
rolling in, but in an effort to address
the, you know, the available the weight
list, but being mindful of the capacity
challenges, that'll that'll be a barrier
we have to get through. And so, anything
you can speak to, I think would also be
helpful. Yes, sir. Um, the the challenge
with the the program is too, we're new,
so a lot of people are learning about
the program and referring some of the
applicants to the district website and
going through that um website to apply.
Um, we have gone to workforce solutions
um recruitment events. We've been to ACC
recruitment events, um Houston Tillitin.
So, we're reaching out to try to be on
college campuses to reach out to those
individuals because those are usually
the people that will work with us um
during the summer and during after
school. Um so, establishing those
relationships. Again, we're this is our
first year in in service, so they're
kind of learning about us and we're
learning the areas where we can recruit
and obtain more staff. And and what I'm
thinking about is is a clear path when
we talk about career progression. I need
I need to know exactly what type of
program needs to be put in place with
whom in order to train somebody to be
prepared. Is it something uh with
workforce solutions? Is it something
with capital IDE? Is it something with
ACC? What is you know what are the
parameters for preparing someone for an
entry level uh into uh child care so
that we can say if if we get x number of
people trained in this process then we
can move them to the classroom within
this period of time. uh maybe can't be,
you know, maybe can't be done this
school year, but maybe it can be a
process that people work through during
the summer and be prepared when we come
back in August or be prepared in
January. But I need to know what the
discrete process is uh the the things
that need to be put in place to prepare
the personnel that we need in those
positions. Yes, sir. Um, in order to be
an entry- level position, they just have
to have a high school diploma or they
can also be in a career prep program
within one of our high schools and still
work for the program. Um, so they need
to be 18 years old or have a high school
diploma. and um they can work for us
because what I what I have found is
particularly from a workforce
standpoint, we'll put programs together
for CDLs for uh apprenticeships with the
with IBW and people don't know about. So
I I need to be able to define something
and put it in front of people so that we
can tell them if you do these things you
can provide child care for your child or
you can be employed in that area.
Um I I'm not trying to put you on the
spot.
I think um Commissioner, you know, as we
think about, you know, we have two
additional fiscal years coming up or
school years. And so you just look at
the weight list that we have at the
existing schools and thinking about
extrapolating that across the other
schools as we fill those up. There's
going to be significant need, right? And
so identifying the pipelines, making
sure we have the relationships, reducing
the barriers, um also interested to
understand how compensation plays into
this uh so we can really understand you
know where that gap is and how we can
approach that and be in alignment and
and and I I won't ask as many questions.
My wife tells me that I'm a little pushy
when I'm hungry. So
So I I'll slow down, take a bite. We'll
be all right.
Thank you. I appreciate your questions,
Commissioner Travillian. And I'd like to
get a further drill down on sort of the
weight list. So in the backup um it says
the current weight list is 325
um
for the current
um and then I know you have the
expansion plans and people are paying in
to that but trying to understand kind of
the the need and what funding is
involved and like if we were doing this
right by the time that you expanded it
out, you know, what does it cost AISD to
provide this and how much, you know, and
that's charging folks and there's going
to be for some people for whom that's
challenging. So, do you have any data
that would help us get at that need and
and the overall magnitude and and then I
guess we have these other programs. So,
what is the interplay? Maybe that's a
question for when we're done to
understand the interplay across um the
programs and what the intention is there
relative to the other programs.
Yes ma'am. Thank you for the question.
Um the program is tuition based so
there's no cost to the district. We run
strictly on the tuition that we receive
from the families. Um, we did receive a
uh childcare relief fund grant several
years ago which allowed Third Base when
it was operating at those five locations
to um save a little bit of revenue to
help with the expansion plans to the
current campuses that we're at. Um, and
then moving forward as we continue to
staff the current programs, we'll be
able to expand um to the new schools um
in a reasonable time frame. Um, they may
not all be at the beginning of the
school year. based on staffing, but it
will definitely be during the 2425
school year. We've expanded to three new
programs this school year that weren't
currently um slotted to come on board
during the 23 24 school year because
there was a need at the campus. So,
Andrews, ODM, and WIN were also added
this school year um because there was a
need and we were able to meet that need
um with staffing and revenue that
collected from the families.
And so maybe one thing would be helpful
is how to if we could expand on how the
information was collected from families
because I think what we're trying to
explore is two or three years out how
would we be able to define what the need
the expected need may be right at that
time so we can begin to align resources
so that we can support our families you
know fiscal year two three and four
obviously continuing on.
Um yes sir. The the need at the schools
um we haven't seen as much need at the
some of the title one schools that offer
prime time and ACE. Um the enrollment
has been very low at those schools
because there's the free programs at the
campus that are already available to
those families. Um so if you see it like
Linder I think has two to five students
that are enrolled there currently. So
we're kind of catching the ones that
don't meet the the needs of that one
program. Um but we're there to fill the
gaps for the others. Um at the other
campuses we're ranging anywhere from 8
to 10% um after school participation and
we project that at these other schools
that have current providers that are
already currently serving programs that
are there. Um so moving forward that's
kind of what we project the need based
on is the population of the campus as
far as the number of students enrolled
and the need that they currently have.
The expansion plan that was laid out was
done so in a manner to fill the void of
the campuses this first year that didn't
have programs already um on board and in
service to fill the gaps to the students
that need care at those individual
elementary schools that um didn't have
care previously. And now we're expanding
out to other campuses um based on the
number of providers they already have in
service and the number of students they
have there.
So though we have multiple providers,
you're one provider trying to meet a gap
and there are multiple providers, some
of whom are doing great programs that we
want to keep those programs and support
those programs.
Do we have a sense of the overall
need for afterchool kind of generally
across all of the campuses and if you
are charging these amounts like how much
that is and then kind of how much the
gap is of where we're not serving it. Um
yeah, I'm not I'm not aware um of an
analysis where where we kind of
extrapolate out uh and based on the fee
kind of what the potential um
opportunity would be. It'd be
interesting to know, you know, the 8 to
10% rule, you know, like we just talked
about, is that a standard that we can
use to model what the overall need might
be across the school district? um
because if it is then we can certainly
apply that um and that'll capture the
need not only that it's being addressed
by AISD but also with our partners right
because they do based on the student
population not just you know what we're
able to to cover so I think we could
kind of back into that but I'm not aware
of an an existing analysis that kind of
gets to your question but we could
probably come up with something that
answers that high level and sorry to ask
another question but for the 8 to 10%
rule is that like how would you think
about that 8 to 10% rule That's 8 to 10%
of the kids need after school care or 8
to 10% kids don't have after school yet.
What what is that measuring?
Yes, that's the 8 to 10% is what we're
capturing. Now, there are some campuses
that are a lot higher than that. Lee,
for instance, is 20 to 23% which is why
there's such a high weight list of that
student enrollment. But the 10% 8% range
is kind of what we're seeing at the
other campuses that we're serving. There
are some that are a bit higher. So, it
could be a little bit different, but
again, um there hasn't been a formal
survey or research sent to to find out
that number. But is that 8 to 10% that
need ASD third base or is that 8 to 10%
that need after school? It would be
after school care. Yes, sir.
And at one of the campus, Blandon, for
instance, there's three programs
currently in service there. There's the
YMCA, Creative Action, and AIDS Third
Base, and they all still have weight
list at that campus. It serves over 300
students every day after school. Um,
Austin is considered a childcare desert,
so there's a large need for child care
in the city of Austin.
Thank you,
Commissioner Shane. Yeah. Is the out of
time uh or out of school time programs
targeted for um students um older than
elementary?
I'm just trying to understand how if
there's any a plan for or capacity for
providing after school services for
older students beyond elementary school.
We do not currently have that on our
model. Um it's just elementary age
students. So, um it's school age which
is um we do have some prek3 that goes
that are full day and then all the way
to some sixth graders that are served on
campuses that they currently attend
elementary school campuses. Thank you,
Commissioner Shay. You'll you'll see
some of that um information in the next
presentation.
So, I have a couple of questions. Um
Council Member Al, you asked the exact
question that I had. Uh so, I would be
very curious. I I know that for school
care is important to all of us. Um we
it's especially critical I would say um
like as we're thinking about the impact
of high quality programs on student
outcomes um and with the state
not really having a very positive um
funding public education funding outlook
to say the least. And so, you know,
really being clear on um what the unmet
need is for afterchool care in in the
city of Austin is one number I would
like to get a handle on. So, not just
for a specific program, but just like
overall, what is the unmet need? Is it
10,000 students? Is it 5,000? like I
have I don't really have a sense of
who's not getting after school that may
not even be on a wait list because there
are families who may not even sign up to
be on a wait list because they don't
know that they can do that and
oftentimes those are our families that
we most need to be reaching out to. Um
and so that that's um what I'd be really
curious about. I don't I don't know if
there have been any studies um at the
city or county level in this area. Do we
know?
Okay. And I don't think we have at the
district I know we have a lot with child
care um like early child care but I
don't see a similar um
um study for for after school. Um, and I
know after school, like there has been
plenty of research. I know, um,
Commissioner Travillian has talked about
this a lot over the years, as long as
I've known you, um, on the potential
impact of after school. And, and that's
really the difficulty that, um, there
are a lot of creative and successful
things happening independently of each
other. And the idea is how do you put an
asset map together that identifies all
of the things that are being done where
they're being effective and then where
they're gaps so that we can expand in
places where successful programs need
resources and we can identify where
similar problems can be addressed on
other campuses with similar resources.
That's right. It's just they're just
operating independently of each other as
opposed to together which is why we
brought all the superintendents
together. That's right. That's right. So
I think so one question for me is can
can this body somehow figure out how to
calculate the unmet need in Austin?
I'm just going to throw that out there.
Austin or the county. I I would say
let's start with Austin. Well, I don't
know. We'll pray for you. I mean I would
say ideally the county, but I mean I
think the Austin Let's start with
Austin. Sarah Stone is here from Travis
County. Hello.
what we find for after school.
Absolutely. Um, hi everyone. I'm Sarah
Stone. I'm a planner in research and
planning and health and human services
in Travis County. And um, one of the I
guess issue areas that I work with is
the youth issue area. And what Polar
just mentioned is something we've been
working on for several weeks now. And
some of what we're finding is that we
don't have the systems within the city
or the county to capture those numbers.
So, um, learn all the time is here
today. Um, can you all raise your hands
back there? Yeah. And they have been
incredibly helpful in figuring that out.
What they have been able to do is look
at the programs um that are registered
with them. You can also do account
through the license programs. We also
have a request from TEA for all of the
programs within title one schools within
the county. There's multiple funding
sources and what we're seeing is um the
need for more support to create a system
to capture the questions that
specifically you and Miss Alter have
been asking. I would say that um we do
have some really strong partnerships. is
a very strong emphasis on quality within
our area which there's a lot of research
that unless you have a quality program
that a place where kids go is not the
same as a place where kids are safe and
respected and have tutoring and have
enrichment and have a meal like
Commissioner Trailion has mentioned. So,
and that's that's the the really
critical point for me because you've got
a lot of people that are being pushed
out of the city because of
affordability.
And I You look at the footprint every
year. You can uh you can just look at
kids that we know through church. Look
at kids that we know through youth
programs and when they once lived in
University Hills or Lakeside or Colony
Park, they're being pushed further out
uh into places where they don't have
systems. So, it's going to be incumbent
upon us to make sure that we are
understanding where people are going,
understanding what's there and expanding
uh the opportunities for them because
we in Mayor a kid can get out of school
at 3:00, we put out uh of a bus and
there's no gymnasium and there's no
baseball field and there's no football
field, there's no nothing. And at the
end of the day, I've got to be most
concerned about who have nothing. And
and so it's going to be important that
we be able to define what it is we're
looking for and understand migration
patterns as people are being pushed out
of the city because of affordability and
gentrification. So appreciate that. Is
there a study that is current you
mentioned um another group um are they
actually doing a study on this and when
when can we get those numbers?
Yeah, sorry. Thank you. We're all trying
and there's multiple sources. So, that's
really coming together. What we have
found is there was a big impact with
COVID with after school funding as we've
all noticed. Um, I also want to make a
distinction. People use the words
expanded learning out of school time and
after school and after school care would
typically between the hours of say 3 to
7 after school specifically, but we're
also seeing a huge need for summer
programming and summer enrichment. So, I
just want to make sure I was glad to
hear about Prime Tam expanding. That's a
huge need in our community. Um, we can
I'll look back over here at my partner
that I talked to and sorry, you're No,
you're in that too. I believe the city
of Austin's really one of the largest
afterchool providers. Um, so it's all of
us kind of coming together and pulling
it together. So, we're on our way. Um,
and I hear your I heard your question
about a time date, and I will do my best
to connect with Polar to see if we can
come up with a specific time. Thank you.
I appreciate that. Um, and then in terms
of the quality issue, you know, it's one
thing to to look at the cost. You know,
of course, we want these to be
affordable programming, but as
Commissioner Trail mentioned, I mean,
the quality of the programming is very
important. How are we measuring that in
AISD? I know that we've shifted, you
know, our approach to after school care
in order to expand it. I just want to
make sure we're not doing that at the
expense of high quality programming. So,
um, is there anything you can share
around that?
Yes, ma'am. Um, we are part of the Texas
Rising Star, um, requirements. So, we
have to be licensed for a year to be
able to qualify as um a TRS provider,
which is I know it's a little confusing
because the teacher retirement system,
but it stands for Texas Rising Star. Um
it's through Workforce Solutions, and
it's uh it's a quality program that you
have to meet certain standards to be
able to qualify for. And then your
program will be um given a star rating
from three to two to five, two to four
stars um based on the the quality of
your program. Um so they actually have
um assessors come out and assess you um
to see the quality of your program and
give you your rating and then that um
also contributes to the uh reimbursement
rates that you get from workforce
solutions uh CCS program. So um we are
working towards that. Seven of our
campuses are already eligible and we've
already started that process um to
ensure that we are providing a quality
program.
Are we also measuring student outcomes
as a result of, you know, participation
in in our programs? Like, are we seeing
an increase in attendance or test
scores, things like that? Um, yes,
ma'am. We did um do an attendance
tracker. So, I think we are maybe 2%
above um the average for the district.
um as far as like the graduation rates
or them um moving on to the next grade
level. This is the first year that we're
kind of where we are. So that'll
probably be something we need to look at
going into next year. Yeah, President
Singh, I think that's a great
opportunity, right, to identify, you
know, how this program is actually
improving outcomes. You know, 2%
improvement in average daily attendance
is pretty significant. Um but yeah,
there are many other things that we can
continue to track and report out on and
maybe even developing a standard for how
we report out would be helpful. Thank
you. And I know that there are other um
like I know that Andy Rodic Foundation
has a long history of of you know
collecting this type of data um and sort
of you know there if there is a model
out there that's already useful um and
used that would be a great probably a
great tool so that we can start having
standardized systems so that we can
collect data from different providers
into one. But I think that's what I'm
getting. It's like if we want to solve
this in a county, city, school district
fashion that we need to start thinking
about this in that way, having common
data sets and all that. So, I appreciate
that. Any other questions or comments?
Well, I just want to piggy back to what
you're saying. Uh,
can you Okay. Yes. Go ahead. if um if
there's a way when you talk about
quality, what does quality mean? Because
um if we could include just literacy in
everything that we do, then that would
be a big way for us to
align with what we're trying to get
students to learn during the school day.
So, is that something that can be done?
Is that something that is being done? Is
that something that's being measured or
you know because we're still not seeing
our numbers where they need to be?
Yes, that is definitely something that
um can be done. It's not currently being
measured, but we do offer homework time
every day um in assistance with um their
their work. It's usually Monday through
Thursday. We give them a break on Friday
where we don't do homework time with
them, but we do have time set aside each
day to help them with their um homework.
Well, it's it's more than that because
like all the programming I'm organizing
at Mendes and and the community love
hub, every partner I have said even if
you're teaching soccer, if you're doing
football, if you're doing uh film
making, reading has to be part of all of
that because they have students have to
understand everything involves reading.
So, it's it's doing it in a way that
they're going to enjoy it.
You put them back in homework, they're
going to feel like they're back in
during the classroom. But this is a way
to connect that reading is with
everything. So, all those enrichment
classes, I have done site visits to many
of them. And I don't see students very
involved. uh they're seeming bored, you
know, so we have to find something that
they really love to do and include
reading in it. When we taught ballet at
Bington, they learned about ballerinas,
important, you know, from kindergarten,
you know, uh when they did cook and read
it and read and eat it. It was reading
recipes and eating what they made. So
always including reading in every single
thing that we can it's to me doesn't
sound very hard to do. Is that something
that can be done?
Yeah. Trust this is Matias. Um I think
as we kind of continue to develop the
program um getting input understanding
kind of what progress you made this year
I think would be a a really good path
forward. um certainly identifying
opportunities to you know create
alignment you know with you know whether
it's early literacy early numeracy
whatever it might be and I think what
we're talking about is if we are better
aligned and we are all on the same page
I think we would be able to get to that
point quicker um I think right now you
know we have programs that AIC overseas
there are programs that our partners
oversee and each of them have slightly
different approaches and so I think what
we're talking about is getting to where
you want us to be And we're certainly
want to get there as well. Right. And
and uh superintendent, could you also
mention uh earlier you mentioned about
compensation. What are we paying people
that are working
in after school and summer camps? Sure.
The part-time rate starts at $20
67 cents an hour, I believe.
Okay.
So, I'm gonna um Thank you, Trusty.
I'm gonna um move us along to Miss
McNeely. I believe you also have a
presentation for us. So, whenever you're
ready
Good afternoon. Kimberly McNeely. I
serve as the parks and recreation.
Um, we have some out of school time
individuals that work very specifically.
However, just based upon our schedules,
I was the best individual to participate
in this this presentation today. So
there may be some questions that you
have that I'll have to do followup, but
I do have a lot of information that I
think is pertinent to the questions that
you have.
So for the purposes of this
presentation, the parks and recreation
department we consider out of school
time uh the the development pro the
programs that are part of the that are
per before and after school and that
they are um comprehensive in that
ideally they support the working
families and they support the needs for
child care that they are safe places for
students and that they also have some
academic support some enrichment
activities. ities and some youth
development opportunities. So in very
simple terms, we talk about that meaning
that you have uh some something that
enhances the school day, either homework
help or some other sort of activity that
helps reinforce force academic things
that are happening in the school day.
You have a healthy snack that helps
children ensure that they are nourished.
you have something that's enriching,
which means that those individuals will
um experience something that they might
not have experienced before that they
may be able to immerse themselves in
later. So, if you like performing arts
or you like um something out in nature
and you find that that's something that
you really love and after school or in
summer camp, we also offer those
immersive activities in other in other
spaces within the parks and recreation
department. And lastly, something
active. We want the children to be um
using their physical getting physically
healthy, right? Using physical activity
to get their energy out and to um to
become uh healthy individuals. Uh the
questions that you asked, I'm just
they're not in here, but I'm just going
to tell you after school program is $140
a week and that is the average cost.
However, the city that is a supplemented
cost because the city of Austin can
supplement programs. Um, beyond that, if
you meet certain criteria, your the cost
of after school is half of that. Uh, so
that would be $70 a week if you meet
certain criteria. And then there's also
an additional scholarship available if
you meet other financial criteria. For
the summertime programs, for the summer
camp programs, it's $560 a week. And
again, there is a additional half off
and then an additional uh scholarship if
you meet certain criteria. So we try to
make that as affordable as possible. We
also for the quality component of our
program, we uh abide by the youth
program quality assessment. Uh so
basically we have an assessor that comes
in our program and observes the children
and and tries to understand through
observation if those children have
different developmental assets. You
know, are they demonstrating behaviors
that say that they they have a sense of
belonging? Are they demonstrating
behaviors that say that they can
conflict resolution. Are they
demonstrating behaviors that say that
they um have self-respect or
self-esteem?
And what happens is is that that's a
continuous improvement uh of continuous
improvement program in that if we are
not seeing some of those things and
you're not going to see everything in
every assessment, right? If we're not
seeing those things or if we're seeing
indicators that the children don't have
those assets, then we specifically put
together training for our team members
to be able to learn a skill set or
strategies to build those developmental
um assets. And we also think about this
in the um youth development program,
YPQ, and meaning that kids need certain
things to be successful. There was a
long time ago before I came here to
Austin, there was a study that was done
that basically said, "Hey, when you ask
children, what do you need to be
successful?" They will tell you those
different assets that they need. And so
YPQ is predicated on building those
assets so that when children graduate
from school that they're able to be
healthy, happy, productive community
members and that they have everything
that they need to be successful. So
that's just the basic part of the
quality question that you had and then
also the the cost question.
So um just we align our programs with
the citywide strategies and also with
the parks and recreation department's
long-term strategies. So those are uh
the different kinds of uh benchmarks
that we have set for ourselves. One
other thing that I think is important
that's not in the notes that I need to
tell you is that we are not uh subject
to licensing. Uh, however, we are
subject to something called local
standards of care, which means every
year in and around April, I think it
just happened. Did it just happen in
March? This week, um, we have to come
before the council and ask the council
to adopt an ordinance that tells us how
it is that we are to operate our
afterchool programs and our out of
school time programs. Our uh, ordinance
mirrors that that is this part of the
state licensing. So it mirrors the um
ratios, it mirrors the qualifications
for the staff that can be uh providing
after school program and it just
essentially is the same as the state.
It's just that it's locally adopted. Um
so that is why we've adopted the YPQ
program, right? Because we have a whole
we have a little bit of a separate
process. It mirrors the state, but it's
just a little bit separate.
How do you address issues of cultural
competence
as you provide your service? I will have
to give you uh I will have to let you
know how we do that. But I know that in
our youth development um assets. One of
those things is cultural competence. But
part of the thing that I would have to
tell you, Commissioner Travillion, is
exactly how we do that to provide you
some examples. But I don't have that
right today. But I will get that. I have
I'm really lucky I have Casey over
there. down all the questions so that I
can provide you the responses. Thank
you. So, we have our programs divided
into some different sections. The
community recreation program is the uh
the main provider of our out of school
time programs. And so, you're going to
see these headings as to the different
divisions of the city of Austin that
provide this. So, they provide things
that are after school. CC camp means
that we have the day camps. When AISD
doesn't have school, we just call them C
camps, which just means that there's an
opportunity for children to sign up for
those camps and then summer camp. And
we're going to talk a little bit about
teen programs. So, our recreation center
program, I won't read this to you, but
this basically gives you the ideas of
what happens at a typical uh summer camp
be pardon after school program at a
recreation center. It's offered at 15
recreation centers and we have 600 and
600 individuals enrolled. We do have
some capacity for 720 individuals which
means that we have to do a better job of
understanding why students in some
spaces we have too many individuals. So
we have waiting lists at c from certain
schools to certain recreation centers
but in other areas we don't have um
enough in we don't have the same number
we don't have a full roster in some
recreation centers and so we're similar
to Third Basin. It looks like we have
some review and some strategies to work
out to make sure that all the spots are
filled and all the children who need a
program are served.
Our summer camp program is uh the same
offered at 15 recreation centers and we
have 720 uh spaces available. And you
might say why are you limiting yourself
to 720 and that's because that's the
capacity of the recreation center space.
Physically, you can only put so many
humans in a given area. And this is the
number of individuals based upon a
quality program. Understanding that
everybody having room to move around,
how much space that we actually need.
And this slide tells you a little bit
about what those um what those programs
look like.
We also have an area called the
centralized programming division and
they help us with our outreach program.
So, I think Commissioner Travillian, you
said, "What about where there's not
something or that we try to utilize our
centralized programming division to do
outreach programming and reach those
individuals who perhaps are not right
next door to a recreation center or
don't have that access. And we we have
community initiatives, teen and teen
outreach and leadership and then also
our therapeutic recreation services.
And so in the community recreation,
here's all the numbers. you'll see we we
serve approximately uh 1,400 individuals
with financial aid and then we have
about 728 individuals that receive that
additional so I told you how we have two
different uh programs um we also have
about 135 enhancement classes that are
provided throughout those um throughout
our out of school time pro I'm sorry
throughout our afterchool programming
and then we provide about 19 I'm sorry
90,000 meals that are free and that is
also part of a backpack program. So at
13 sites that qualify for the backpack
program on weekends, children go home
with a backpack uh with some basic
essentials for themselves over the
weekend and then also for um for their
families. I'm not here to say that it
feeds families of 10 or anything, but
it's a certain amount of essentials home
with them. And then we also have 19
sites participate in the summer food
program and that includes six playground
programs that we have. It's important to
know not every site qualifies, right?
There has to be certain criteria that a
particular area of the city um that you
would meet. So not every area of the
city is qualified for these programs.
Our outreach team uh for our youth
program, we have two we have a couple of
programs. We have teens in leadership or
we call it the tilt program. Totally
cool, Totally Art, and Roving Leaders.
Roving Leaders is exactly like it
sounds. It goes out into communities and
picks up children who might not have
exact direct access to a recreation
center and either takes them somewhere
or brings the program to them so that
they're able to um immerse themselves in
these different ideas. So, we have
things that related to public relations
and social media and being able to be
behind a camera and production. We have
sports leadership where ch children I'm
sorry teens are learning not only about
the sports and the sports skill skills
but how to be coaches or how to maybe
perhaps later on um coach in our area in
the parks and recreation centers where
they can actually be paid their skill
development depending upon sometimes
that's robotics sometimes that's coding
just depends upon the particular skill
cooking essentials that's culinary arts
again each of these are trying to help
um students that are in that teen
learn a skill that might take them
somewhere else, might give them a job
opportunity. Um, it might actually just
help them at home, right? If they can
cook better, then they're making healthy
meals for themselves and then they're
eating good stuff with their family. Um,
we did this in program hours because
it's hard to say exactly where they're
at, right? Because it depends upon where
the outreach hour. So we ask we we
measure this particular program in
program hours and so over 1300 program
and it's a free programming to teach.
The summer playground program is also a
free program. It's free drop in Monday
through Friday from 9 to 5. It's
primarily serves children ages 5 to 12.
If you show up and you are older than
that, we are absolutely going to accept
you into the program or have you be a
part of the program. It's just that the
activities are geared for ages 5 to 12.
Um when you're younger than five, we are
not equipped to take care of um
children. However, I just want you to
know should a three or four year old
come with an older sibling. We figure
out how to manage that. We're not going
to tell children that they have to go
and sit in their house instead of
participating in that playground program
right down their street. We figure it
out. Um these are spread throughout uh
the the city. North, Central, and South.
There's only six locations. And um you
might say, well gosh, why aren't you
doing more? And the honest reason is
just because of the available funding
for this program. Um but we did have
over,200 enrollments in 2023 and
obviously 2024 is coming up. So we'll
have different numbers for that. This
flyer tells you a little bit about those
programs and the locations.
The other service that we're able to
provide and I think this is in alignment
with things that AIS AISD is able to do
but we provide therapeutic recreation
services and so for individuals who have
disabilities and um are choosing a
program that is uh specifically for
individuals with disabilities and it
could be cognitive or it could be
physical. They might go to the McBth
Recreation Center or the Alamo or the Dy
Jordan Recreation Center for those
services. But I also want you to know we
have what we call inclusion services
which means that if a mom or a parent
somebody a guardian signs the child up a
child up for a after school or a summer
camp program and indicates that there
might be some uh reasonable
accommodation that is needed for the
child to be successful at any of our
locations. Then have a mechanism by
which to provide inclusion services. And
usually that could be some adaptive
equipment if that's what it is or it
could be an an additional individual in
the ratio to help a child be successful
in that program. And so we have a
individuals that are certified
therapeutic recreation specialists.
They're part of our therapeutic
recreation program. Those individuals
help with the evaluation and then
actually can provide different goals and
strategies while the child is
participating in the afterchool program
as part of therapeutic recreation to
help further some goals that might be
consistent with things that are
happening in AISD or frankly for some
parents it's just they just want their
child to be able to have fun this summer
and take a break from that. And I'm not
saying academics are important. I'm just
saying that's what some some parents are
saying to us and so therefore we just
provide whatever that that child needs
to be successful in the program and
here's a little bit about our um about
the numbers surrounding that.
So we have these immersive programs and
immersive programs are also museums and
cultural centers and so they also have
afterchool summer camp and teen
programs. These programs are
specifically uh I think Commissioner
Travillian you asked me about how do you
help with cultural competency. I think
it's important to tell you how we do
that in general. I'm just going to call
it general. But in these immersive
programs some of them are specifically
around particular culture. So
individuals sign up for this program
because they really want to learn about
that particular culture or about that
particular thing. And all the programs
here are are related to the theme of
that particular camp. And so obviously
the Asian-American resources about Asian
culture. The DHY Art Center is
specifically about arts. The
MexicanAmerican Cultural Center is
surround is about the Mexican-American
culture. And the George Carver
Washington Museum immerses children in
um in the Africanamean culture or the
black culture. I think that they have
since expanded um their
ual competencies. And you're also going
to see in here when you want to immerse
yourself into nature, there's also those
programs. And so here's a little bit
about the programs that are offered at
the cultural centers. This is just a
basic understanding of those. We
actually have a summer camp that is
bilingual at this particular time,
specifically bilingual for
MexicanAmerican or Mexican um using the
Spanish, sorry, Spanish.
Here's a little bit about those
programs. I'm just going to go very
quickly. Caminos is the immersive
year-long program. Uh it's an internship
that is specifically for teens. And then
we have uh other support leadership
programs at the MexicanAmerican Cultural
Center. Um we have public outreach at
the MAC and we also have um different
exhibits that the youth will put
together that we'll put on. And so these
programs, not only are they uh
entertaining, but they're also teaching
some of our youth some skills at the
cultural centers. Um, these are some
other programs. The work in progress,
which is an immersive program that
prepares teens living in uh, Austin if
they're interested specifically in the
arts. This is offered out of the Dory
Arts Center. And then also we have um,
the Doherty Arts Center is part of the
cultural programs within the recreation
center that commits to addressing
economic and racial inequalities within
the city. So teens from historically
marginalized communities are especially
encouraged to apply for the WHIP
program. Um these are the nature center
programs with the Kamacho Recreation
Center. It's really an outdoor uh active
recreation program. They do things like
how to ride um dirt not dirt bikes,
mountain bikes. Um they have a a filming
component. Um they have a film festival
at the end of the year. They do caving,
kaying, canoeing, everything outdoors.
So, if you're in the summertime or
walking the trail, you might see a group
of 12 to 18 kids riding on a bike.
They're probably part of this program.
There's 122 classes, um 274 hours of
programming. It tells you all the
participants by the numbers. And then we
have our Austin Nature and Science
Center. Again, immersing children in
nature. They have about,00 participants.
Um they have uh even in the heatwave, we
figure out how to offer these programs.
And so we have um 655 campers that are
ro enrolled across 10 weeks. Um they do
things like also out of the nature
center kayaking, caving, snorkeling,
animal presentations, and then learn
about floor and fauna and how to be good
stewards of the of the um of the
environment.
Um we also have park ranger cadet
program. This is very specific to teens.
It's in a relationship with the Aikens
or it used to be in relationship with
the Akens um where we have a cadet
program and the cadet program uh we help
prepare young um young individuals to
become cadets and so it's a feeder
program into the um park ranger program
but also this park ranger uh cadet
program and the park rangers themselves
try to enhance particular programs that
are uh free programs to children. So we
have something called boredom busters.
So, in order for those children to get a
because it's a free program, in order
for them to be able to have some
experiences and some immersion and
exposure to things that they might not
otherwise have, this is an outreach
program that goes specifically to board
and busters to make sure that they can
enjoy um nature activities. And so, on
specific days that parents are okay
with, we will take children kaying or to
other um other locations to experience
something that they might not get at
their u at their recreation center.
Um, something very specific that I
thought was important to mention is the
fact that we have a really great
partnership with AISD with a
superintendent Sigura in order for us to
have green school parks and that green
school parks allow uh children to be
immersed in nature. 80% of the children
across the world are living in an urban
setting. Um this particular program
allows us to have 21 schools where we
are uh partnering with the school
district to be able to create spaces
that are not only just for learning but
immersion into nature and allows
children's and family to use it not just
for the curriculum in the school day but
then also after school. And so we're
incredibly thankful to the school
district that while this is not
necessarily a specific summer camp or
after school program and is an out of
school time uh program that AISD helps
and allows the uh the families to be
able to access the school even when it's
not open for schooltime business. That
was a lot of information. Happy to
answer questions and if I can't answer
them, I will get the information to you.
Thank you, Miss McNeely. So, I think we
have time for one question. That was
very good. But really quickly, yes. Um,
I appreciate the explanation of what the
programs are. I'm interested in who the
programs serve. So, we try to do at the
county is identify where where we locate
the program, where it physically sits,
and then who it serves. Gives me an idea
of the of the places where where we're
serving kids and then the gaps.
I'd be interested in knowing where
you're located. I could map those for
you, Commissioner, and send them. Yes.
So in those in those um areas where the
cultural centers are in a specific
place, we only have one cultural center
it set, you know, of of a particular
kind in a but we can tell you where
those uh where the participants are
coming from. So we will map that for
you. Thank you. Thank you. That was such
an excellent presentation. Um so much
good information. And chair, I'll just
offer my kids have done several of these
camps and they really are remarkable and
also just the park pickup um program in
the summer. It's a really remarkable
offering.
Thank you. All right. Uh I mean
President saying I I have a just a
comment. Um I know one of the areas um I
visited the summer camps this past
summer. Um, and uh, one thing that got
my attention is uh, I know that mental
health first a day training is something
that um, uh, our rec center staff would
be very excited to be to be able to do
because our kids go to the to the rec
centers after school and in the summer.
And so, uh, Miss McNeely, is that
something that y'all are staff getting
mental health first training?
Yes. Uh, Miss Sapata, thanks to you, you
sent us that information and we have
been able to schedule um three different
classes that for mental f mental health
first aid and uh 90 different staff
members will be attending that and it's
going to occur at the end of April and
the beginning of May. I've just
forgotten the actual dates, but um thank
you for your advocacy and for sending us
that information. Excellent. Thank you
so much.
Thank you so much to both of you. So,
next on the agenda is an update on the
child care working group.
Somebody else going to present on this.
Okay. All right. So, next on the agenda
is an update on the childcare working
group by council member Alison Alter.
Let's limit this discussion to about
seven minutes if that's possible just
because we got a late I will I will I
will definitely do my best and just want
to point out for everyone that there's
additionally some background
um also in the backup um for Austin
public health after school programs um
you know we at the city have been really
trying to lean in to this and to support
after school programs recognizing um the
importance and you know one of the
things people know about that we're
doing is prime time but there's a
serious series of other options that um
deaf put together for us um there. And
so if you have questions, I'm sure
public health will be happy to answer
them afterwards or or in the future.
Where is it in the back? It's in this
booklet at the section B.
Um so for the for the child care um
I can't remember when we met in January
what the date was whether we had passed
it or not at the city but um we have
adopted um Prop 2 from the state which
allows for the 100% child care exemption
um at the city um and um I believe the
county Jeff or or um Bridget if you want
to chime in. I believe the county
adopted it as well um last week. Um so
we will have both county and um city tax
exemptions for child care agencies. We
don't have an exact number of how many
agencies um will be impacted. I think
the city was operating off of a 100
number and the county may be 50. So we
just somewhere in that range. Um there
are qualifications that they have to
meet. Um, and they also do need to apply
for the exemption at TCAD, but I believe
that TCAD's using the same exemption for
the city and the county in terms of the
form um to be able to do that. Um, so
folks do need to apply for that. Um,
that is something it's, you know, one of
many tools that we are trying to move
forward with. Um, the working group at a
very high level is continuing to make
the case for the importance of child
care investments. Um, I think that as
you go out in the community more and
more um child care is being tied to
workforce needs and we're hearing over
and over again um whether it's our
workforce programs or whether it's our
employers that part of the struggle that
they're having in finding um workers is
the lack of child care. Um and that is
above and beyond everything that having
quality child care can do um for the
kids. Um so we have been focused on kind
of making that case. Um and um we
continue to be working through um
whether we will pursue this opportunity
at the county or the city in terms of
having ongoing funding. Um
and um we have in May at the city we
should be hearing back from our staff
about how we can provide um similar type
of assistance to prop 2 for our family
based care providers. they're not
eligible according to Proposition 2 for
that. Um, but here in Austin for our
youngest children, um, family based care
is a very important component. Um, so we
want to see what we can do because they
own their own, they're working out of
their homes. It becomes more
complicated. Um, but we believe that we
may have some opportunities to do that
and that should be coming back to
council to look into in May. Um, and
hopefully we'll be able to take some
action with respect to that. Um, then I
want to see if Commissioner Trailion or
Commissioner wanted to say anything
about county discussions. Um, we'll be
really interested to see what
information you get about how to uh
provide those uh tax exemptions to
homebased child care because that is
it's an issue and there's a lot of that
kind of care being provided. Um, I I
also want to just um say I really
appreciate with the tax exemption that
if um the tax exemption goes to the
landlord, but it's the tenant that's
providing the child care, the landlord
has to sign an affidavit um indicating
that they have passed along the
equivalent savings from that tax
exemption in in the form of a rent
reduction for the child care operation.
uh if uh if it's in a rental facility
and we identified about 50 I think in
the in the county for that uh service
just really really important thing that
we're doing. We want to make sure that
we're doing the best thing for the
greatest number. So appreciate the work
that's been done that we're working
together. I think that we're a lot
stronger when we align ourselves and
work together.
Seven minutes on
Thank you. Thank you. And and we have
such opportunities here. Um and um
hopefully we will we will be able to
move forward um with something big that
will affect many many children and many
families in our community and many
employers and um you know appreciate all
the information earlier today and um I
think with that we can wrap it up for
now. Thank you so much um really
important work that you all are doing.
really appreciate it. Thank you. So, um
the next topic is something that's near
and dear, I think, to all of us, and
that's mental health. And we are very
fortunate to have um I'll just say one
of my favorite people in the district,
Dr. Twilight Williams is here along with
Dr. Kimberly Wilson from AISD. So,
they're going to present to you. Um so,
in your packet is an overview of
behavioral health services offered by
Travis County Health and Human Services.
Trusty, I mean, President Singh, how
much time do we have for this item? Um,
we can do I think 20.
Let me double check.
I think we could do about 18 minutes to
like for Yeah, let's let's start with
18. We be able to stretch that out a
little.
Mike, good afternoon. Thank you all for
this opportunity. We are excited to be
here to discuss mental health. Um I am
Twyla Williams. I'm the executive
director of counseling mental health for
Austin ISD. And this is Dr. Kimberly
Wilson who is the director of crisis
management and mental health. The
picture that you see on the screen is
what makes up our team. And we'll talk
to a little bit about um who's on the
team. It's our social emotional learning
cultural proficiency and inclusiveness
team. It's our trust based relational
intervention or our trauma informed care
and our counseling coordinators um that
are represented on on the picture.
In our counseling and mental health
department, we provide comprehensive
counseling program that addresses
academic, social, emotional learning and
mental health supports for all students
through a trauma-informed lens. What
does that mean? That means we care for
all students, their mental wellness,
from the area of them being mentally
healthy to mental illness and the
supports that are provided. What you do,
what I believe you have in your packets
are the mental health supports that are
combined. It's a report that is combined
of what's offered in Austin ISD and what
is offered in the county and the city
plus you and how those supports work
together. Um, because you have
information we can go back over it at
the end of the presentation.
Um the next slide what you're seeing is
how we function in the counseling mental
health department and it's through a
multi-tered system of support. Um and
with our tiered supports it outlines
each one of those programs or each one
of those uh teams within the department
that we share. When we think about
school counselors, we think about um a
lot of people who play school counselors
with um academic counselors and that is
a part of what their role is. But
academic counselors or school counselors
also play a very big part in um
supporting our students through their
mental health journey or their mental
wellness journey. The part the role of
the school counselor begins with the
tier one side of it and tier one is
preventative and it is for all students.
It is the mere fact that where school
counselors will provide relationships
with students. Um as students experience
different levels of needs, the school
counselor is there. So it begins with
the school counselor and it stays with
the school counselor. The school
counselor is one of the constants that
is on the campus supporting the
students. Sorry that um supporting the
students um with any trauma that may
arise or any mental uh wellness or
mental illness that may arise as well.
When we look at tier 2, it's a school
counseling, but it's also individual or
group. So maybe the classroom lessons
may not be enough for all students, but
it's an opportunity to identify greater
needs. And when those needs are
identified, then counselors are able to
work individually with the students and
they're also able to form groups. say if
there's they notice um through a needs
assessment that there are students who
um whose parents or caregivers may have
experienced divorce. So student
counselors can then pull those students
together and offer group sessions for
those students. Um as we move into
greater needs, the tier three needs,
that's where our licensed mental health
professionals come in for intensive case
management and also crisis intervention
as needed. And we will talk more about
that. When you look at the top tier, um
that is where we um identify the needs
of students that where they may need
short-term counseling through Ros School
mental health centers in Austin ISD,
which you will find more information in
just a second about that. as well.
I would like to mention um the AIC
mental health initiative which is an
overview of what we are planning and
what we are actually currently um
creating at this time. With this
overview, it is an initiative through
our superintendent um Matias, excuse me,
and our board of trustees who we are
very grateful for to invest in student
and staff well-being and mental
wellness. And so with an overview, what
we're looking to do through the
multi-tered system of support is provide
professional learning for students and
staff and families. Um we heard the
mention of mental health first aid which
is one aspect of the training. But we
are looking to train our staff in the
next three to five years for early
indicators for early platforms, early um
opportunities before it gets to the
point where there's a crisis or where
there's an outcry. So we're really
looking the preventative. And one way to
identify the preventative is to know the
signs, to know the early warning signs
and knowing how to track that track
those signs which or even to be able to
identify those signs as we are working
through um looking at different
platforms for u mental health supports
to be able to identify those. Uh we are
also looking at the role of the school
counselor. The role of the school
counselor was created for academic
outcomes to ensure that our students are
getting what they need. And when um
trauma arise or when certain issues
arise where students are not able to
perform and do um well, that's where the
school counselor role is is to help to
identify to help address it and to help
to um integrate the students back into
the classroom. Another part of the
mental health initiative um are
school-based mental health centers which
um we have 31 licensed mental health
professionals um and we have the school
mental health centers that are designed
to be on every campus and so we have
some further statistics as we go through
the program um superintendent would you
like to add to the mental health
initiative? Um thank you uh Dr.
Williams. I I think for us as an
organization, you know, it's really
about identifying where we want to be in
two or three years and recognizing that
it cannot happen overnight and many
things have to be tied to the budget
approved by our trustees before we can
even take the first step. Um so what I'm
I guess proud of here is you know we
identified an initiative we created for
um kind of areas within it Dr. Williams
just mentioned the four, but like you
know the just even having the mental
health spaces on each of our campuses. I
mean we have 113 campuses. So
identifying this space, where is it
located? How are you going to fit it
out? You know, where are the funds for
it? Um all of these things uh take time,
but we have a thoughtful plan and we're
well underway uh in getting there. The
other thing I would say is the platform
that was identified as bullet three.
That's huge, right? So, we have an
immense amount of information that we
receive every single day, right? We're
tracking attendance, we're tracking, you
know, uh, grades, we're track tracking
everything that occurs with our students
within our campuses. And so, we're eager
to um expand our platform to identify
those students who would otherwise maybe
be invisible. Right? If a student had
A's, you know, all last year and all of
a sudden they drop down to be a low B,
high C student, you know, that might not
be, you know, it might not raise any
alarms, right, for the vast majority in
a big high school, for instance. But if
you correlate that with an increase in
absences, if we've had the student for
many years, you know, this is, you know,
not a typical behavior, then all of a
sudden we can begin to identify those
students and with the support of the
campus get um than the support earlier
than we would have otherwise because
it's just not as um visible. And so
we're really excited about that
platform. It's something we would not
have been able to do two years ago
because we didn't have the larger
platform, the ERP system in place.
And that's more common than you think.
We had a kid, fourth grader, straight A
student, goes home for Christmas, comes
back, is not interested in school, puts
his head on the table. We find out that
he learned that his mother had terminal
cancer. That's right. So, how do we
address where do we address on a campus
by campus basis? That was really
important. and I will think Jean Spencer
who was a member of staff at that time
who who found out went and talked to the
child made the diagnosis
it was and and that's a perfect example
that might otherwise be totally missed
right and and so we have a lot of
information we can pull from and so
that's going to help empower us to make
the right decision earlier. Absolutely.
And in addition to that is streamlining
our systems because we have where in
some aspects we're doing doing it really
well in
we are not identifying it until it's at
a place where we wish you would have
identified it earlier. So again, it's
about streamlining the systems and
having a place a um system in place to
be able to track or progress monitor um
the support for our students.
Um we talked about the um school
counselors and the role of the school
counselor. So this is a slide. We
currently have 172ish school counselors
and a new role that we have is also
wellness counselors. And so the wellness
counselors and the school counselors
serve together on the campus to provide
those tier one and tier 2 supports.
I wanted to briefly mention our brain
science brain based learning based on um
Dr. Bruce Perry and this is where our
trauma care um integrates with our tier
one supports. This is where we um go
into the classrooms and we help to
identify trauma that students may have
and we do it um holistically as we are
working with the students with their
individual college and career military
readiness plans. So um we know that what
it may look like is a stu a student may
go in to see their high school counselor
to talk about graduation requirements.
The counselor may identify the student
as someone who may be homeless. So we
can't just keep talking about what are
you going to do past post-secondary
readiness when you've got the situation
that you're dealing with now. So what
that would look like is making sure that
we provide the wraparound services or
that we identify what the needs and how
to help the student to stabilize that
individual situation. So then we're able
to then move on to discuss what's needed
for graduation and beyond.
Um I also mentioned that a part of our
uh department is the social emotional
learning and cultural prof proficiency
and inclusiveness team and within this
team this is where we have our um
department that is tier one um could
also be tier two or tier three needs as
well but it's identifying what those
social needs may be those emotional
needs may be also the cultural
proficiency side of it. How does race
impact how a student is learning or how
they're not able to learn? How does that
impact how they're um interacting with
their teachers or interacting with uh
fellow students?
Um and this is just the three signature
practices that goes along with the
social emotional learning um aspect of
of our department.
Hi everyone. I'm Dr. Kimberly Wilson. I
am the director for mental health and
crisis management. And so I want to talk
a little bit about ASD wellness
counselors. This is a new position um a
fairly recent position in tier 2. And so
when we look at the multi-tered systems
of support, we're looking at again the
school counselor being that um that get
that friendly face for for students on
the campuses for teachers and
administration and for um and for the
whole campus. But once it reaches a
level where you know add additional pull
out is needed or maybe more counseling
supports or counseling is brief
counseling short-term counseling is
needed um in the areas of maybe a
student maybe um is going through a
divorce or maybe poor pre- relationships
but they need more of an ongoing
support. Wellness counselors can provide
that and so as you see we do have like
17 and a half um wellness counselors to
do that. So that's on the campus level.
The next tier um in terms of where my
role come in and the team that I support
um is looking at from I guess the
district level the trauma-informed lens
on how we support campuses as they
support students and so we provide
direct counseling support um and when we
talk about the levels of crisis that
could be the daily crisis of uh students
with experiencing self uh harms uh self
ideation it could be um of a larger
crisis dynamic where we have to go out
and as a team and support the campus
during a critical incident.
And so and and because we we serve
campuses who already support and and
students in campuses and then the staff
there, we again that tier three model.
So 10% we're thinking a max of 10% of
the student population, but that's the
intensity of the needs that we have. And
so when we look at tier three, it's not
all students. counselors make referrals
to our team and it's based on you look
at the child study team meetings the
student support team me's a lot of
things happening at tier one tier two
when the services are exhausted or again
the students need a little bit more then
a referral is made to the licensed
mental health professional this is on a
dayto-day once the refer you can once
the um referral is made then we decide
we you know we we work with you partner
partner with the family, we partner with
the campus and say, "Okay, how what can
we do to best support your student um
your child so that they can feel safe,
they can be safe, they can have
increased positive academic outcomes and
we look at we look at attendance, we
look at behavior um and we look at the
emotional wellness of of and the the
state of being that their family is in.
And so based on that we decide with the
family like uh whether we refer what's
internally what's internal supports and
when we talk about mental health we're
talking about the whole child we're
looking at are they connected in the
campuses in your packet I think in the
mental health supports we talk about
other programs that we partner with are
they connected to because the sense of
belongings is so important so once we do
that and the family says you know I
really parent or guardian like you know
they really need a little bit more maybe
they have some barriers we have the
licensed mental health professionals who
can provide their licensed um either
their licensed um clinically social
workers, licensed professional
counselors and they just have to have a
license with the governing body. So it
can be an element too. We just don't
have any right now. So they're so based
on that if it's where they have barriers
and it's best and it's preventative for
them to offer direct counseling, we can
do that in the school mental health
center. And right now
Oh, right now uh I am proud to say that
we have about 94 school mental health
centers. Now, there are some barriers
with that like superintendent said, you
know, in terms of trying to make sure
that we have designated space because at
some campus we just have to share um but
we want our um our counseling experience
to be a quality a quality of care for
our students and families. And so out of
the 94 uh centers we have about 52 or so
that is either shared. So we have they
they actually go to the campus and have
a center. This is an example of one. I
just you know we have an example of one
and this one I want to say this is the
one at Anderson. So, if you would go to
Anderson, Anderson has a I'm gonna say
the word, we have a portable, but it's
our portable. And um but there are uh
two equipped rooms and I have them
rotating out. So, it's not just about oh
31, they serve one. No, we go where the
need is and so but and it's rotating.
This is short term. The beauty of the
team also is we're working with families
and if it's something that is um that we
be able we'll be able to provide
preventative strategies strategies to
coping strategies and they've mastered
their goal great but and if but if they
need long term we work with that family
to connect them and so I always say we
don't you know we're not turning anybody
away the need is there and we're going
to be able to meet that and so along
with that and tier three support this is
intervent this is the intensive needs
We work with our CIT, our crisis
intervention team through the Austin
Police Department.
I'm Austin ISD. Yeah. Police. Yeah.
Austin ISD police crisis intervention.
Get that straight. And so and they too
have a team and one of the team members,
they have the um police officers, but
they also have a social worker also that
provides crisis response. She's our
coordinator and we work in tandem when a
when a student who is in crisis um and
it reached a level where we we have to
like um you know what we call have an e
emergency detention PED when they're in
crisis may have to be hospitalized then
we work with the team when they are at a
high level of risk. So what do you use
um for your evaluation model? How do you
evaluate the effectiveness of your
services? Okay, very good question. So,
this is the first year and so what we're
doing now, we have a s um survey
satisfaction. So, um parents and
guardians as well as students. So, we've
designed a sur uh a little um
satisfaction survey and it's about five
questions and for ele and it's and it's
developmentally based. We have uh icon
shapes with icons for the babies because
we do have unfortunately we have some
you know prek kinder um and then we also
have uh for secondary we also have a
different um the same questions
infidelity but it's geared toward their
developmental understanding and then for
parents and caregivers. So right now
this is what we're sorry right now this
is what we're using and hopes to grow as
we grow the uh mental health initiative
that's going to be a part of the
measurement process but we needed
something to make sure that we're on the
right track. So superintendent and and
board chair uh Dr. Joyce James is
probably the best of the best. Uh
whatever is good about the state's
program she put together uh and it works
in the area. Um I know that we do some
um truency work in um in um JP1
that addresses family therapy and family
needs and it's already on the ground and
they're working with Prairie View in
order to get that done. there two or
three resources that are on the ground
that we should probably try to take
advantage of and wouldn't have a great
deal of cost to them but would deal with
some of your core issues and and many of
the core issues grow out. So I would
certainly be willing to to connect you
to both of those systems and make sure
that we're getting the best we can.
Thank you.
Yeah, one of the things that um I'm
seeing more and more literature on is a
growing um climate anxiety particularly
among young people and I'm just curious
um if you're seeing much of this if this
is something that the the counselors are
equipped to address or if they are um
seeing this surfacing much in in school.
Yeah, very good um noticing. So I will
say last year we saw a little bit more
of the social the anxiety piece the
social anxiety this year we do see a lot
of the trauma related to um post stress
of things that occurring and
unfortunately these the trends when we
look at the trends and I meet with them
monthly about hey what what because I
want to see if it's per vertical team
per feeder school pattern per area is
this something that we're seeing across
the board and what we are seeing is that
there's a lot of anxiety related to
family dynamics the culture it could be
a lot of um family violence we have and
even in the if you watch if you look the
correlation within the news of all the
different um you know crime related to
family violence it it impacts our
students and so they're bringing that to
to to school and we're able to um not
promises promise them a sense of safety
but give them u a sense of a safety
where they can feel safe be safe and
have coping strategies around that. So
that is a hot trend but not as not as
high as it was last year. Just just to
piggy back on, I've got a I'm on another
program in a few minutes, but um the
family violence piece is critical and
important because you've got parents
having to make the decision, well, this
is violent, but if I leave, can I
survive within the context of leaving
and so many choose to stay in a
dangerous environment. So how do you
know how do we understand how do we
address how do we put the resources that
are necessary to put people in temporary
conditions uh if violence is at the core
uh that is a a difficult and expensive
area uh to work within but sometimes we
are talking about life and death. So
ma'am may I add one more thing? The
other thing too that is a noticing is a
is homelessness
um eviction kids are fearful you know
having instability within the home. So
that's another trend that we see and um
that we work with our partners um in
terms of community partners our shelters
and all that to make sure that we have
they have case management there. But
that's another um uh trend that we see.
And just to add a resource to that,
we've um hired and allocated funds for
legal assistance for people facing
eviction. Um and I what would be the
best way to to reach that reach out and
access that kind of resource?
So they can contact
city and county.
But we also um uh have attorneys that
we've funded through um
Texas Rio Grand Legal Aid and other
legal aid organizations. And do they
contact them through Elwen? Right. So if
they're at the at the eviction getting
really close to eviction, they would go
through Elwen and Elwen would connect
them to those legal services as well as
assist
them through the uh to prevent the
eviction if the eviction were still to
go through then they can assist them
with relocation assistance. Thank you
for that. We we're that's a good partner
for us. Thank you. And I also wanted to
I'm sorry uh just real quickly about the
the family violence and the different um
issues, even anxiety. We look at it from
the standpoint of the whole child and we
look at it under the umbrella of safety.
So, we're working um with other
departments as we discuss safety because
it may be mental wellness, but it also
may be physical safety. So, it's under
the umbrella of the safety um and
supportive schools program as well.
Thank you so much. Excellent
presentation. really this is an ongoing
um conversation but really appreciate um
both your leadership on this issue.
Thank you.
All right. So before we lose any more
people we will move on uh to the next we
got two more items. One is um the
planning year for the summer youth
employment program. Um there is a
written report I believe
in our backup documentation.
Is that correct? Someone tell me which
tab. Oh 4. Perfect. Thank you. Um and
trusty Sapata had to log off but um I
know that this is her baby so I'm sad
she's going to miss this conversation
but does anybody have any questions? Um,
is there anyone from um the the city um
that might be able to to speak to this?
So what we included was a lot of
information based on um our presentation
from last time uh we presented on this
program last time we were together and
uh we added a few more slides on there
to tell you a little about uh the new
things that we're doing with a
mentorship program interviews
and um um more of a
helping the kids with a smaller group of
number of kids so that the quality is
better. Um what I believe um trustee
Sapato was interested in was to know
more about the planning year what that
meant and uh we did uh decide to
increase the number of kids to serve.
Last time we presented we said we would
serve 300 train 500 and actually place
300. So we have raised it to 400 uh
based on the requests that you all made
and Trusty Sapata made. Um, and also
just to let you know that we have um had
a a preliminary discussion with AISD
and uh the Texas, not Texas, the
workforce solutions
um and the city of Austin to talk about
how we can um take the program to the
next level, evolve it. is is it uh
better administered outside of the city
and the county to think about those
options if there's if there are any. And
so we um we're continuing to explore all
the ways that we can work together and
collaborate.
Thank you. Um how awesome that we're
going to be able serve 400 students in
this program and it's a seven it's a
longer program. Correct. Right. We took
it from two sessions uh to one session
and it increased it from five weeks to
seven weeks. Great. Thank you. And these
kids get paid. These kids get paid. Yes.
And uh last year we increased the the
hourly rate from $725 to $13 an hour.
That's great. Um all right. Are there
any questions?
Is there uh one quick question? Is there
confirmation on number of spots that are
being made available between the county,
the city, and the school district?
We don't have a confirmation of the
number of spots. I know that the school
district did really really well last
year. We thank you very much for opening
spots for for the kids. Um I know that
uh we have more spots outside of those
three organizations than we do in those
organizations.
Right. So um app appreciate that. All
right, so now we will move to the last
item which is um
unfinished business and new business and
proposed future agenda items. So I'm
open to hearing suggestions.
Um I'd be interested to uh get a
briefing on the um
um whether or not there is um education
related to impacts of climate change and
preparedness happening among um any of
our three entities. The school district
to me is the obvious place. Um we've
been working on a lot of uh different
community preparedness initiatives at
the county um just to try and better
prepare people for the impacts of
wildfire and flood and um increasingly
destructive weather that's impacting our
region. Um and I know there's a lot of
pressure on the school district um in
general um particularly from from the
legislature and people who are not
supporters of public education. Um, but
I'm just wondering if there's any
opportunities to um
use um the natural learning abilities of
children to help families be better
prepared
for increasingly frequent disasters. It
may be a taboo subject, but um I think
it's it's worth at least asking the
question.
Thank you.
We may want to go back and revisit um
some of the issues that ISD was
experiencing an update on how you've
handled it and understand you've handled
a lot of these really really well and
want to give you that opportunity to to
come back and and inform us on that and
um you know I need to digest the
afterchool information and you know put
it together with the work that we're
doing on childare. It may be appropriate
to have a broader discussion at the next
meeting. I don't know on the timing um
but I think there's there was a lot of
questions that were raised with the
after school um where it'd be great to
have a better picture of that and you
know obviously AISD is here so it may be
that getting okay this is what we think
is the need in AISD and then
extrapolating out thinking that AISD is
probably the better served of all the
districts
at least um for many of them that that
would be kind of something we could
extrapolate out and that would give us a
minimum need as opposed to a perfect
assessment which may be impossible
because if we were providing subsidies
we might have more kids who needed the
child care. It's it is very expensive um
for many of these families. Um and so I
think it would be good to get a better
better angle on that. Whether this is
the right form for that or not or
whether it happens faster I I don't
know.
I'd be interested in that too. Thank
you.
Madam Chair, I've got one other issue.
Um, and there there probably won't be
time. um uh it'll be past the deadline
by the next joint subcommittee meeting.
Um, I've recently learned that with the
upcoming um, Texas Central Appraisal
District elections, which are now
mandated because of a change in state
law, that there is the potential for
school districts to be actively harmed
in terms of um, their tax revenues if
uh, people who are um, I would say um,
anti-ax or anti-government get elected.
um uh and um somehow impact the
independent nature of the appraisal
process. Um I've seen now 16 different
examples where if appraisals were deemed
to be um outside a 5% margin of error as
determined by the state controller who
audits the appraisal districts. It's
only the school districts that have to
repay and in some cases millions of
dollars. Um, so I think people need to
understand that um this is not an
opportunity for people who don't like
taxes uh to run for election and try and
um really upset the whole system. Um and
that people need to understand that
there's a potential very serious
financial threat to public schools um
should that happen.
And the election is May 4th and
virtually no one knows about.
Thank you. Any
other items? Yes. I just wanted to point
out that uh Travis County did submit a
report in regards to what we fund
school and summer programming. Um it's
at the very it's the very last page on
your packet. Um so we just wanted to
make sure that you have that.
Thank you. I want to just ask um our
city reps here. Would it be appropriate
to have our um I believe you all might
have been are in the process of hiring a
new city manager. Um would it I don't
know when that person is going to be
hired and is there an opportunity maybe
to have a have him come and introduce
himself? So I think it'd be great for um
him to come assuming everything moves
smoothly this week. Um we don't know
exactly when he's coming on yet. Um it's
will be, you know, mid June, but
hopefully a little sooner than that. And
I just don't know that the timing will
work with the next meeting. I'm not sure
we can ask that in the first two weeks
um that he's on, but but certainly the
one after would would definitely sense.
The next one will be June 10th at Travis
County. you're hosting us. Thank you.
All right. Um Okay. Any last comments?
We're actually on time, so that's a
miracle. Thank you. Do I have a motion
to adjourn? Yes. All right. Motion from
uh Commissioner Shay, second by um
Council Member Alter. Um
do I have to f raise your hand? Okay,
it's Thank you. The meeting is ajourned.
Really great information. Thank you. at
1:28 p.m. Happy eclipse to everyone.
Thank you.